Tanzania East Africa the epicenter of an
ongoing crisis a country where lions are
switching their sights to focus on
humans as fair game
on April 10th 2008 Musa feces Shabani
a young builder and his older friend
Munna were riding their bikes
there were near home but so too was a
300-pound male lion running at full
speed
lucila wanaka lion it just came out from
behind us and started chasing us within
seconds the lion was in striking
distance I was very scared I was
trembling so much I thought I was going
to faint he was chasing us and roaring
and that's when my friend fell off his
bike that doesn't affect you the lion
leaped down on his back and dragged him
to the edge of the highway standing on
the roadside
rucifee see witnessed Munna being mauled
by the lion at this point I ran I felt
like I'd lost my mind hadas couche near
a human lion conflict expert has been
researching man-eating lions for four
years her studies suggest a startling
change in lion behavior adult Lions may
now be teaching their young techniques
and tactics for hunting humans there's a
common misconception that most Lions
that that cause these attacks are old or
sick and that's actually not something
that we found to be true here in
southern Tanzania sometimes we find
young lions healthy lions taking part in
it that we think that they are teaching
their young
it was while defending their crops
against marauding bush pigs that a savoy
whatas family was devastated by a lion
attack in the middle of the night his
father mother and two nephews were
dragged out of their shelter and eaten
the exact picture of what happened the
lion he took my mother first and ate her
there up to the waist and killed my
father and put him aside and took the
children he arranged them almost next to
each other so that when my brother went
to look for them there he saw the
children first and thought they were
sleeping despite this tragedy a Savoy
and his relatives continued to sleep in
the fields guarding their crops from
bush pigs he says they have no choice
after four years of studying man-eating
across Tanzania hadas cush near is also
convinced that rainfall patterns are a
central factor in the recent rise of
man-eating prides
El Nino is a worldwide weather
phenomenon that results in super-sized
flooding across East Africa the floods
forced the game animals to seek higher
ground with the result that some prides
of lions find themselves marooned with a
limited supply of food it's at this
point that they are forced to go in
search of human prey from what people
told us it sounded like if you get a lot
of rain you have animals in places where
you wouldn't normally have animals or
you're missing animals in areas where
you would normally have animals many
scientists predict the global warming
will likely increase the severity and
frequency of flooding events if the
connection between flooding and the rise
and outbreaks of lion attacks is proven
to be true the future looks bleak